all right good evening everybody members
and visitors welcome to the Development
Committee the 11th of September 2018
significant delayed from when it should
be in August our apologies for that
unfortunately the council had some
fairly catastrophic IT issues which
meant that the proper preparation
couldn't be done and as all of our
planning applications are treated with
the utmost seriousness we needed to
cancel the meeting and to delay things
until we were happy that all the
information had been properly gathered
I'll start with our emergency evacuation
procedure which is that should we be
required to evacuate the building would
you please leave the building via the
nearest available exit to the chamber
our assembly point will be in the public
carpark at the side of the Civic suite
please do not delay your evacuation to
collect any belongings and please do not
return into the building until given
permission to do so by council staff
please also note that the meeting won't
be recorded and if you have a phone
please silent it or turn it off thank
you
our apologies have been received from
councillor Ayano who's been substituted
by councillor F D and our non members
attending councillor Stanley Gooding
Haviland sparing
mark mark Roe and Merrick thank you
eventually got there
okay minutes of the meeting held on the
19th that ya said that one yeah minutes
of the meeting calendar on the 19th of
July 2018 they happy for me to sign
those as a correct and accurate record
of that meeting thank you
declarations of interest
that's the Mel a member of Rayleigh town
council and on one of the issues the
goldsmith Avenue in the town council
wrote a letter but it does not influence
in any way okay that's America
okay thank you
we'll move then straight on to our items
believe most of our visitors tonight are
here for item eight so we'll take that
one first just a quick explanation of
the way it works the officers will give
their independent report first of all
they'll then be the opportunity for the
two people that have already registered
to have their have their say for a
maximum of five minutes then our
non-members will get the opportunity to
make a speech if they wish then it'll be
a debate open to members who will
discuss the item prior to ultimately
taking a vote you may hear some things
that you agree with you may hear some
things that you disagree with
unfortunately you're not able to take
part of the in the meeting by
contribution and it is important that
all members are able to hear everything
that is said clearly so if the something
said that you particularly agree with or
disagree please keep us as star to cap
on or on the noise as possible so mrs.
Frank's started off then please Thank
You chairman this application is to a
site on the south side of Goldsmith
Drive to make the junction here with
whole bridge road you'll see the Raley
Club golf course and it's an area of
plot land that has mixed uses you'll see
a scattering of residential dwellings
and sand isolated businesses but also
vacant clear
plots the site is within the
Metropolitan Greenbelt allocation it's
also within flood zone 1 which is the
least risk of flooding zone where
development would normally be directed
the site as you can see on there was
formerly open grassland with some minor
hedging up to the sides and a more
substantial hedge at the back before we
pressed on I would firstly correct the
report of paragraph 7 which members will
say from the detail on the image and
plans that will follow that number one
and two Goldsmith Drive located here are
actually detached dwellings and not
semi-detached if we can jump to the
location plan please the application
site is edged in red as your see here
here's that sort of hedge to the LA
Bard's area at the back goldsmith drive
along the top and one and two Goldsmith
Drive located up here you'll see that
the application was revised there's a
slightly different plan in the back of
your agenda which includes sort of like
a c-shaped site following
representations made by the people who
owned this land the applicant revised
the site to their ownership and you'll
see it widens at the rear there if we
can jump to the detailed layout please
thank you the application involves the
creation of an access that comes down
into the site into this turning air at
the top there's a fence there and a row
of hedging and a sort of a turning head
- at the beginning of the site and
you'll see that an area at the back here
provides two static caravans and
tutoring caravans and one day room if we
can jump to the just briefly the day
room it's a simple building about nine
meters wide four point six wide and four
meters in height overall with a pitched
roof and you'll see it provides an area
with a toilet in a utility room now that
is pretty standard for traveler sites if
we can jump back to the layout again
please you normally find one pitch in
planning technical terms comprises a
static like a more permanent residential
base and an ability for the touring
caravans to be parked and then add a
room that that's pretty standard
provision in this case the day room
would be shared by both plots it's not
unusual sometimes to find a day room on
each plot the application you'll see was
made in late 2017 but more recently in
July this year whilst the application
remains too outstanding the applicant
commenced work and a South Park provided
a more substantial area you'll see from
the officers report that the area shown
on the plans equates to something like
217 square meters but this is a much
larger area now
that's been surfaced and that is
separately subject to enforcement notice
the fence line not the hedging has also
been constructed members will also see
from the site history on paragraph 15 to
the report that an application for a
poly tunnel which is on this side of a
small nursery that does tend to get
picked up in the site histories that we
report to there's a technical reason for
that I think the site overlapped in the
way it was plotted but to make clear for
members that polytunnel application is
for the site next door it's not for this
site now the development proposed as you
can see in the Greenbelt
is inappropriate development members are
probably pretty clear with that it was
an open undeveloped site and this any
development really on there would be
inappropriate that's it for agriculture
perhaps and you'll see that officers
make that point in the report however
members will be aware that there's been
two similar applications in the vicinity
of the site one at the former pumping
station in watery line which was
slightly different in that it
constituted previously developed land
that is bit likes a bull Woodhull which
is a good example a development that was
in the Greenbelt but that became
redundant and has been given a new
permission for redevelopment so the one
in watery line was also for a to pitch
traveler site that was on previously
developed land and officers on that one
recommended to you to refuse and the
application was refused and there was
another application if we can just jump
back to the location plan if you can
clear was on here now though I think the
owner owns all of that site which is 20
meters or so away from the site the
actual distance between this site and
this corner is about a hundred hundred
and five meters this why that says it
that way on the report now significantly
both these decisions were appealed by
the applicants officers recommended both
to be refused in light of the government
policy 2015 and in the watery lion case
the appeal was allowed it was granted as
a permanent gypsy site conditional to
gypsies not personal
to the persons who were applying but
it's it's a sight that can be reoccupied
by different families and in the case of
the one on halbridge road that was made
personal to the applicant and his
dependents who were applying now in
those cases the inspectors acknowledged
that it was inappropriate development in
the green belt they acknowledged the
added harm about the urbanization which
was the council's defense but they were
highly critical that the council hadn't
met its allocation it's it's provision
which now amounts to some 19 pitches
prior to 2033 and the the scenario that
future gypsy site provision would be
likely to be met from what is currently
green belt in future allocations now
perhaps because the watery Lane site was
previously developed land the inspector
made that permission permanent in the
Woodville site that you see here the
inspector anticipated that there would
be future releases coming forward in
your local plan emerging by 2020 they
would need to be then a time to obtain
permission and then build that site out
wherever that may be so he granted
permission for a five-year temporary
permission for this one here and that is
what largely framed the recommendation
that's before you tonight we've
rehearsed the policy issues but we've
been tried and tested on two recent
occasions the appealing watery Lane was
given in November and the appeal on wood
and
hobby's wrote the decision was was in
February this year which is both very
current and in the context of the
current policy so on the addendum
members will see that there are some
further representations from third
parties which I won't go through because
members obviously had a chance to read
that but what you haven't seen we've had
a letter since the addendum was
published from a resident and 51 the
drive hull bridge and I'll just read it
it's not a long letter it says I am the
owner of six plots of Greenbelt on the
junction of Maple Avenue Goldsmith Drive
and have been so for the last 27 years I
wish to object to the above plan and
application on the grounds listed below
which
greenbelt illegal application of the
occupation of the land why is this
person allowed to do so when everyone
else has had to comply with the
restrictions on Greenbelt the location
submits plan is submitted is incorrect
no mains water down Goldsmith Drive any
planning has to comply with the
structure being in keeping with the
surrounding buildings a caravan mobile
home does not by I urge you in the
planning committee to dismiss this
application on the above grounds as this
will have a detrimental effect to anyone
living down the road or people that own
Greenbelt plots there the recommendation
chairman is approval subject to the
conditions you see set out in the report
strannix mentioned the addendum are just
one final check everyone's seen their
damned and got access to the addendum
yeah okay our first speaker is as the
Marissa from up to five minutes and let
you know when you got a minute to go
[Music]
Thank You chairman good evening members
this is another retrospective
application to create a travel site in
the Greenbelt in the Rochford district
government policy states that if
applications are made after the
development has been started
then this should count against the
application and it is surprising that
the officer is excusing the applicants
total disregard of planning law
government policy states that traveler
sites are inappropriate development for
the Greenbelt it also states that
traveler sites in the Greenbelt should
only be advanced through the local plan
and not as a result of the planning
application development in the Greenbelt
should only be permitted under
exceptional circumstances and these have
not been demonstrated in this case the
officer has stated that this represents
harmful encroachment on to the Greenbelt
and his country to policy gb1 and the
National planning policy framework there
are other reasons why development in the
Greenbelt should not be permitted and
local residents have raised most of
these destruction of hydro damage to
wildlife and Greenbelt discharges into
water courses of treated or untreated
effluent density of local travel sites
accessibility to the site visual impact
of the development lack of water mains
damage to local biodiversity and access
for emergency vehicles despite these
numerous different and valid operative
objections the officer has recommended
the granting of a temporary consent of
five years that is this is effectively
permanent particularly when travellers
children become registered at local
schools paragraph 41 of the report
states that refusal would be detrimental
to the interests of the child but
government policy states that personal
circumstances and unmet need are
unlikely to clearly outweigh harm to the
Greenbelt and any other harm so that too
has established very special
circumstances of which there are none
who are will ensure that the families
and caravans are removed and the ground
is returned to its original condition in
2023 our DC's enforcement team are
already overstretched the officer has
recommended this consent in the face of
numerous veiled objections because RDC
has not met the current requirement to
provide a deliverable forward supply of
travel pictures in the district but
again policy states quite clearly that
the Greenbelt is exempt from
provision so they would appear to be no
real reason for the opposite officer to
support this consent other than the
belief that our DC will lose on appeal
this is pre determination the officers
must judge all cases on their merits on
how they are guided by government policy
and the local plan and on the comments
and objections made by all consul teas
and not what they guess a planning
inspector might decide the purpose of a
planning Authority is to plan
development for all types in accordance
with the local plan and government
policies particularly for traveler sites
not simply to approve applications such
as this on an ad-hoc basis for green
belt land where travelers choose to live
local residents must be listened to and
not ignored by officers listening
they're listing their objections and
then ignoring them is unacceptable this
is entirely responsible it is entirely
responsible means the book sorry for
these residents to expect due regard for
all material planning objections to
fully and fairly applied government
policy to ensure that recommendations
are in keeping with the letter and the
spirit of the local plan to avoid
injustice to any parties when
determining planning applications our DC
officers have abdicated their
responsibility in meeting these
reasonable expectations and it's
therefore only right the members rigidly
set recommendation I urge you to do so
members should be aware that other
similar applications have recently been
made on green belt land in watchos
districts and many more applications may
be expected due to our DC's failure to
provide a located traveler pitches these
failures should be addressed now it
cannot wait until the next local plan
the requirement for sites needs 3 met by
RDC in areas that are sustainable are
closed to utilities and do not
contradict planning law or are
detrimental to existing residents which
this application appears to be the
government policy states that they
should be true regard to protect local
amenity and the local environment and
that peaceful and integrated coexistence
with the local community should be
promoted this site is being enclosed
with a 1.8 meter high fence isolating it
from the surrounding community hard
standing has already been laid a cesspit
installed and the local residents object
to it I urge members to refuse his
application thank you
okay now how spine
[Music]
thank you good evening I'm speaking to
object on behalf of myself and all other
local residents this is in addition to
all the matters raised in objection
letters and the addendum what I'm about
to say can be a substantiate it and I
hope a few photos will be shown one of
the planning requirements has set out by
her majesty's governments that allow
travelers to receive special planning
concession is that the traveler must be
working if not they are dealt with under
planning as the settled community
planners need to know which one of the
two criteria a traveler falls into the
only way to prove a traveler is working
is for them to produce documentation to
prove their income via HMRC accounts or
p60 for an applicant to be able to just
say he is working in an abuse of process
the planning officers appear to be of
opinion that travelers do not have to
prove this I would ask the planning
officers where does it say they do not
have to prove it firstly I draw your
attention to some of the errors that
were found in the officers report which
the officers have seen fit to
acknowledge tonight since their 5th
September report but I'm going to carry
on as my speech is written item 1 the
office of report States hard standing at
the rear the sight to be approximately
217 square metres but approximately 1080
square metres of Greenbelt field has
actually been covered in hard standing
there is a further approximately 360
square metres of hard standing forming a
road on the site the word approximate
cannot be used as a defense for this
error to the office of report states
opposite the application site is a
semi-detached pair of dwellings in fact
there are two for bed detached houses 3
the officer's report states that to the
west of the site is a polytunnel that
appears to be in a state of disuse in
fact this fields thriving active
business with the polytunnel put in for
use the planning officers appear to be
dismissing the immediate area around the
application site whilst completely
ignoring and miss research representing
there is nothing of note including an
obvious nursery business for the
location plans enclosed with the latest
officers report still shows land not
by the applicant the true owner of the
land made planning officers were of this
land grab and that the original
submitted plans were inaccurate the
applicant has since submitted a revised
allocation plan showing the true
boundaries why does the current officers
report still contain the wrong location
plan five the opposite report states the
application is approximately 105 meters
from another traveler site in fact
boundary to boundary is 20 meters apart
six once again the nursery has been
totally ignored and the polytunnel
approval has been given to the
application site why is this is it
because of the scientists that many
planning applications refused even on
appeal seven talking of previous
applications to were refused by officers
one reason being there was excessive
amounts of hard standing the present
application has a similar amount yet the
officers now approve this it's still
Greenbelt what's changed 8 the
Development Committee had been aware
made aware that mark Francois MP had
written to Shon scrutton lodging a
formal approach into this application he
has specifically asked his objection be
noted in the report that would go to the
Development Committee it was not a
neighbor contacted mr. Francois
informing him of this omission which led
mr. Francois to resent his letter to mr.
Scranton expressing his disappointment
he'd not been included I understand the
Development Committee have now received
a copy of this letter and comments have
been noted in tonight's addendum mr.
Francois is letter wrong with other
objection letters have not been logged
on the planning portal why surely is
everyone's democratic right to be heard
and acknowledged secondly at 7 a.m.
Saturday 14th July mr. O'Brien and his
family set up an illegal camp on the
application site one applicant the
family have been harassing neighbors for
an illegal water connection all have
rightly refused to applicant and son
visited fairways garden center to use
the toilets they totally abused the
situation and the son was recorded on
CCTV going into the female toilet when a
lady was in a cubicle next door wrecking
the toilet by pulling the lid off the
pan and leaving excrement everywhere
just a minute ago
three soon after this they were seen
acting suspiciously before stealthily
entering two properties at night digging
and burying pipe to connect an illegal
water supply which has now been
terminated the police were called to
investigate
applicant son came to my home and also
other neighbors with a Walter Walter
Fisher who asked if mr. O'Brien
into our private supply of the water
meter we would receive the water bills
but would have to ask the travelers
ourselves to pay for their portion in
six and suck up foot water have since
informed us this proposal is legal
illegal they had no one work in an area
that day in fact they would not call on
houses for this reason we have no idea
who was impersonating water board
official but as pensioners this is very
disconcerting and intimidating behavior
obviously all this is having a terrible
effect on local residents and we're very
worried about the future this item was
referred by councillor Stanley I'm
presuming you like to lead us a lot to
leave my comments to the end if I may
know as a visiting member you're only
able to speak before the members yes
I'll be before them at the end of the
meeting members okay do any other
councillor row Thank You chairman and
can we be sure that we have all the
information in front of us now I had mr.
Gandhi at mark Francoise surgery on
Saturday morning clearly stating that
this letter hadn't been forwarded to our
or hadn't been put in our documentation
tonight and we received it yesterday are
there any other documents I miss in
there any other letters that have gone
into the offices that haven't been
presented to us as I find that quite
shambolic 6th of august that letter was
dated and we've only we were only heard
of it yesterday
thank you I think just saying on
applications there's often lots of
representations as members we don't
receive a copy of every representation
it goes to the officers for their
independent research an examination and
they will often sum up within their
report the nature of the responses that
have been been made but I can
if you'd like to chairman that the
reason for the postponement for such a
long wire was to hopefully capture the
letters that we thought were missing
while we had the IT breakdown so there's
been needed to get past that and then
allow time for whatever letters we could
retrieve or find to be presented to you
so that's why there's several on the
addendum that you see tonight that
that's because they've been submitted it
may be four five weeks ago perhaps but
we best we can establish we think we
caught all those that have been
submitted yeah carry on thank you as I
said that letter was dated the 6th of
August we didn't have OIT problems then
we definitely didn't and mark Francois
specifically said he wanted that letter
in and in this report so I'm very
surprised that this came the day before
the meeting their office members wish to
speak that's the Stanley then thank you
Kevin
first of all my I say that from the
previous speakers are on this issue that
this is a green belt we are dealing with
the site had its own ecological area
before work was undertaken and yet we
have not had to be pumped on it before
occupation we should have been in this
report from the offices and together
with the report on the cesspit that has
been installed without permission the
plot did have a hedgerow and water calls
which is not been stated which could
have been used if the cesspit
which could be used if the cesspit
overflows which i believe should not be
used for that purpose
furthermore the size of the plot these
41 meters by a hundred and six meters
there was a parcel to land owned by
another resident and I see up there that
this has been now altered to correspond
with what the other occupier as he's
occupied taking into account this a man
I'm removing from that figure would
leave 3000 square meters of which the
best part is later cleanings and hard
core the mobile old homes would be
approximately nine meters each and we
take up half the half the width of the
soil which has that this has not been
correctly put on the side plan as you
say above I asked I have a question you
asked about the dayroom whether this is
to be a fixed dwelling or a mobile
dwelling which could be removed in that
five year period in the end of the five
year period should that have to be and
as we know it it's not really desired on
Greenbelt as I fixed building is the
occupier a Romany gypsy or a traveler
we know that the parcel were land on the
watch which the officer referred to he
is a true gypsy and with that without
any question it is without now without
doubt the whole exercise will be visibly
intrusive a detrimental to the
relatively open and
development plot a blame character of
the greenbelt thank you thank you okay
so that now concludes the part where are
visiting members are able to take part
their members cast a scepter please
thank chairman I'd like to some bits of
clarification plays on what we've been
presented no particular order here on
the drawing that's on the screen there
where the day room is there's something
just a little bit to the north of that I
can't quite make it out make out what it
is
so is it a circle what's that yeah okay
thank you that's what I wanted to
clarify what reasons has the special and
the applicant given special reasons has
the applicant given that would negate
the Greenbelt status with regards to the
water supply they've obviously created a
water supply I'm curious to know what
how are the other property is supplied
within the road there are they on our
teas and wells or quite how is that
supplied you mentioned in in the earlier
presentation you referred to the situs
proclaimed now I'm sort of aware of what
plot lanes were but in planning terms
what significance does that have within
this scenario and the question I was
going to ask which councillor Stanley
has already said is with regards to the
dayroom is that a fixed brick-built
building is it a temporary building is
it on a slab what is the design
characteristics of that particular
building it doesn't show any footings on
the drawing there so I'm assuming no
that's just a some form of temporary
building okay thanks Jim catch the hoc
way
Thank You chairman firstly a question of
the offices in relation to how we view
this overall application in the addendum
some of the information that was
provided by some of the people who've
written into the offices there's a
question over as to whether under the
current government's recent alteration
and definition in relation to as
individuals are defined as as travelers
there was a question as to whether the
person who was putting this forward
actually qualifies under that recent
alteration as as a traveler on that
basis if if the individual doesn't meet
the criteria is a traveler then the
officers argument about this application
would fall on its feet so has there been
anything to sort of define the
individual as a traveler and as current
legislation can you is there anything I
thought of so I want to gather the
questions together and every other thing
is is that I'm so the officer made
indication as to recent planning history
in relation to what's happened in on
other sites relating to inspectors to
but their results so in in some of the
information the addendum where there was
a successful appeal or an unsuccessful
appeal because objectors were able to
put argument forward which the inspector
agreed with which would go contrary to
what the officers had stated as to and
that would be an argument to say that
that would go against what the sort of
like are there the current history
because it would show a a situation that
happened in to the opposite of what the
officers did but also I find it
concerning that it was a decision that
was made by the development committee
against officer approval but yet when
when yet matter went to appeal there was
no no no planning Department involvement
in that appeal
and the decision was was made on the
basis of other evidence provided by
their individuals so it would seem that
we're not getting the full picture of
recent history in relation to decisions
made by inspectors okay that's the
Wilson thank you chairman I've got a
number of questions first of all this is
discrepancy at Paris six and forty one
that paragraph six it says that the
proposed occupants will be the applicant
his wife and their two children
additional proposed occupants are the
applicants son and his wife but at
paragraph 41 the applet or the agent for
the applicant stated that the applicant
wants to ensure that his sons children
had proper access to education if
they're not born then the five years
doesn't really apply for for education
so that's the first point the second
point is that it was mentioned that an
enforcement notice was placed on the
applicant is building work still
continuing in spite of the enforcement
notice because that might lead lead you
to think about how they might act in the
future going on to the the whole bridge
road site I'd like to know was did
construction work start there
before the appeal decision was given or
was it after the appeal decision a
question I think so yeah
future actions of someone can't be a
part of a planning decision that we make
and through the planning training that
we've all had we know that people can
and do sometimes start on a planning a
start on a development without planning
application without planning permission
but that's done at risk it shouldn't but
it shouldn't deter me be a determining
factor in our decision tonight okay make
that point okay and the with the I note
in the officers report that not just in
Rockford but other parts of the country
there's been this this temporary
five-year period for occupancy has that
have any of those periods ended anywhere
do we know and what was the outcome of
that and then the final one is about the
access to water and and my understanding
is from a child welfare point of view
that access to fresh water is actually a
very important consideration thank you
okay it's about time we summed up some
of these questions and plays Thank You
chairman dealing with them in Reverse
the access to water isn't primarily a
planning reason sorry chairman the
access to water isn't primarily a a
planning reason water can be brought on
in containers applicants can pay to have
a connection made in the case of the
watery Lane site there was I believe
water or at least toilet facilities on
the site for the workers on that on the
pumping station but the applicant on
that site once he got his permission he
negotiated with the adjoining farmer to
pipe the water across the adjoining
field etc the temporary five years
there's only one that I can think of
that had a long history in New Park Road
that's in in Hockley off the lower road
area and that that went back to
something that 2004 when that first
there was a series of temporary
permissions and there was a change in
ownership and I struggled with the
detail with that joven though I dealt
with all those applications but I think
an inspector made it personal to the
applicant for the last time period
because there there was no success
insights coming forward so I think after
several years of temporary permissions
including two different families
occupying the site I think that now runs
on a personal permanent permission the
long term education point raised the I
don't know which one but the applicant
is basically proposing a static for
himself and then he son that he's
anticipating that his son will also have
children which I take the point about
the five years but that's the approach
that the inspector took that ahead of a
future allocation that might find a site
a temporary permission was justified
members no doubt will take a view on
that
now the question raised about the appeal
the council actually did officers did
provide a a defense I've read the
inspector said no statement was made but
I've looked on the file and we did send
one what we did has often advised by the
inspector at the Inspectorate when we
when we meet them occasionally in
training sessions they make the point
there is no need for endless duplication
and because the reports on that
application was quite full the history
the site descriptions etc all what was
required was that the reasons that
members took be articulated so we wrote
the planning inspector a letter
explaining members findings on the night
so we did give a defense but it wasn't
the traditional defense that officers
might provide in in full in terms of a
document size where we perhaps recommend
refusal and it's all full of all the
evidence that we've relied on as it was
a member
decision obviously the only evidence
we've got in an appeal is what members
say on the night so that translated into
three paragraphs or so in a letter now
in terms of the definition we've
approached the applicant on the basis of
the question that was asked of us of
wild goal about providing work the agent
told us over the phone that the
applicant travels and leaflet drops and
he did say he would try and source us
some of those leaflets but that hasn't
happened we haven't heard anything from
him on that since now that is the same
question that was asked in the other two
appeals I was present of both of those
the watery line and the whole bridge
road appeal whereby the inspector like
we did they just asked the applicant to
confirm if they was a traveler they
didn't ask the documentary evidence and
then proceeded to a decision members can
take their own own view on that in terms
of the playroom being fixed sorry the
day room being fixed there isn't a lot
of detail as members saw we know its its
size and its shape and its appearance it
could be of a timber construction we
don't know the details I believe if
members are minded to approve it there's
a condition that asks for the details to
be submitted timber structures are more
easily removed than say brick built ones
but as I said in the presentation
Dave rooms are are a traditional feature
of gypsy pitches because they're their
culture requires them to do the sort of
laundry and ablutions in a separate
building outside the the the sort of
family home so if you see a designed
gypsy sight traveler sight pitch you
always see a static iturra and a day
room I think
plot plot land definition oh yes plot
land that that really was as members of
this district we're probably familiar
uncomfortable with plot land I do find
that inspectors struggle with it
particularly as traditionally they're
normally from outside the area and the
plot land phenomenon is a historical
legacy of our landscape where you get as
a result of agricultural depression and
the advent of the railway you've got
sigh Oh to the railways because the
railway bought land above market price
in a recessionary period and then
divided areas up into irregular plots
and unmade roadways and then sold them
all off before the First World War on
big champagne parties so you get this
sporadic development after the impact of
the two world wars where some plots were
left vacant and overgrown other people
at holiday retreats then in the longer
term a more up to date people have made
those into dwellings and homes so it's a
term that describes something common to
South Essex and also South London areas
outside of London generally influenced
by a railway where it's not unusual to
find a substantial house next to an
overgrown scrub plot or perhaps then a
horse grazing in the next paddock and
then somebody running a small business
you know a few hundred yards further on
it's a mix of sporadic development which
I hope made clear unlike the more
anticipated view you get on approach to
other towns across the country where you
run through farmland or moorland or
something and you come to an age of the
settlement the plot land in this area
tends to be on the edges of our built-up
settlements in terms of very special
circumstances the applicant has relied
on daily the lack of supply and the need
for accommodation and lack of sights
thank you chairman
questions there I don't think we got
clarity on the the children we mentioned
the son who might move into the police
next door is there any additional
children I think
I think the discrepancy was around the
education of the the children and its
carry on making your points and we're
authors and and then the the whole
bridge roads site that was was shown to
the right of this I believe there was a
question around whether this applicant
moved in prior to all developed on the
site sorry and occupied it before
receiving permission whole bridge road
sites the applicant awaited the decision
and then when he got his appeal in his
favor he then began the process of
implementing the decision is partially
implementing on the site as we speak the
information I have with regards to the
applicant for this site is only what's
in paragraph six whereas he says the
occupants of the site would be the
applicants his wife and their two
children and then in the other static
that you see there would be the
applicant son and his wife now I think
the applicant is anticipating that the
applicant son his older son would
subsequently have children that's the
best I can offer members with the
numbers of children that would be on the
site carry on
and I'd prepared some things to say
however a lot of its being said so I'll
just pick up on the other pieces where
we may have disagreements I believe that
moving in and developing essentially is
intentional unauthorized development has
been a material consideration since 2015
therefore believe it is worth taking
into consideration and as well as the
welfare of the children I think one of
the the reasons given as to why we
should consider temporary permission
here is that the National Planning
policy for traveler sites and its
document and the specifically part in
paragraph 27 where it refers to a local
planning authority not being able to
demonstrate and up to date five year
supply of deliverable sites and this
should be considered into a
consideration in any subsequent planning
however there seems to be an exception
where the proposed land is on designated
Greenbelt area such as this and so I'm
not I'm not sure if therefore that
exempts that and we shouldn't recognize
this as a material consideration any
clarification on that would be useful
thank you
--kavitha Griffin okay interesting
Thank You chairman two questions about
electricity supplier a is the site
connected to the grid and B if it isn't
are any generators running thank you it
counts the Steptoe Thank You chairman I
just want to clarify a little bit more
on with regards to plot lands yes I I
understand the way plot Lance came in to
intervene and that plot nodes were set
up to help people get a footing on the
housing ladder the at the time the
planning was perhaps
laxen it is now and at the time people
just used to park a railway carriage or
something like that on house the fact
that it is now Greenbelt negated any of
that of the plotline or is there any
still relevance to Portland as you
mentioned that it was and just can't
quite understand where the status is hey
Thank You councillor mill my questions
really about permanent and movable
structures we've got two types of of
structure on this site and it's not
unknown in the past for a static caravan
to have a skirt put around it and in
concrete pumps in and if someone claims
later on it's a permanent structure is
that we're aware of that because when we
go down the line and they're there for
years and years and if things don't go
well in the future to do with temporary
planning and then it runs on can this be
a problem in that we would find that so
they would claim that there's a
permanent structure they're living in
though okay thank you chairman dealing
me the last first you're right in that
people have looked for loopholes where
they're just looking to establish a
residential dwelling they've looked to
they perhaps bring a temporary building
on wheels onto a site and claim its own
it benefits from sort of temporary
rights and then they've made it
permanent over time they put fixtures on
on the skirt you describe I think this
is slightly different because what we're
dealing with is an issue of a traveler
sites where by their very nature that
mobile homes are static and they may
have ultimately a permanent base but
they don't need to prove a permanence to
get round an enforcement trick they if
they're dealing with a different policy
and a different issue so they're not
they're not coming along and saying how
I've been established here for more than
four years and fixed to the ground and
therefore I'm entitled to a certificate
of lawfulness so that does happen but I
don't think it's highly relevant in this
case because the applicant is making the
application
that they are just on on the plotlines
points
members are right that Greenbelt when
when it washed over the district prior
to the 70s it brought within tighter
controls and yes a lot of the dwellings
that are there have been denied
extensions and things like that under
your Greenberg policies but it I think
an inspector particularly would be
looking at the concept of openness which
is important to the Greenbelt I've
explained it in the presentation in
terms of there was nothing there on the
site and it is inappropriate in that
context but then the inspectors on the
two decisions have gone on to say well
future site provision will be met from
the Greenbelt some way so that nullifies
that out that's that's the issue and in
this location
sporadic developments scattered about
our part of the makeup of the character
in terms of the the children on the site
there is a hook in the policy about the
best interest of the child that if
enforcement action is taken planning
permission refused that action has
consequences on the child's education
once they're settled in schools the
ambition of government for a long time
has to be provide travelers with a
settled base so that access not only
schooling but but also medical services
etc so if they haven't able to
demonstrate somewhere else to move to
that the need for a settled base weighs
heavily to clean inspectors and an hour
decision-making I think I've covered
other than arranged school I can't help
members with whether there is any
electrical connections as say typically
travelers can provide their own
generators but they may also as they've
done in watery line particularly once
established make connections to the grid
but no I can't help you with whether
there are generators running on this
sites at the current time I don't I just
don't know there may be there may be not
I don't know to come back down to the
hook way
I don't know if there's any other
members have got any other questions
proposal before before you do our I'll
just say a couple of things shuffle word
so that's the Western name thank you
thank you chairman question wants to ask
I understand
buildings already going ahead or gone
ahead on this side if at this point the
end of this meeting is refused is the
building still going to carry on while
it goes to appeal or are RDC going to
carry on lodging what they were doing in
the first place that was just my
question we can't predetermine what the
actions of another person might be
Chairman okay now there are stop notices
in place but I think they were timed
around this decision-making event so I
presume and I'm looking at my colleagues
know they're finishing sorry
for how long
yes yeah they were issued on the 13th of
August against further engineering up
operations but I would imagine whether
there would be a need to reserve any
house in the future I don't know I'm
being told not so so there are stop
notice in in place that should in theory
prevent the continuation of of the work
of course if they if they do carry on
then they're in breach of the notices
and could go to courts or they may
choose to Lodge obviously the appeal
against the refused application if
that's what happens I'm I'm still
unclear on the status of the children I
apologize and so the two that we mention
is one of them the the Sun this is
proposing to live in the caravan next
door in which case is he of school age
and a second one can we confirm that
they are indeed of school age how old is
this second child or indeed
chairman art don't have the I you geez
I'm afraid I think the the debaters has
been quite fallen to their to this point
and I I don't think there's a whole
amount of new stuff that can be thrown
in from my point of view I think when
we've looked at previous sites we've had
the officers interpretation and we've
had members interpretation of of all the
evidence and on balance we've made a
fair decision to refuse applications
however those applications have gone to
appeal and they are very very relevant
to what we see in front of us and in
fact one of them it's about it's just
about 20 meters from from from the site
here and for all the interpretation that
we do an officers do an independent
planning inspector has essentially said
that an application like this is
acceptable with a five-year position
with a five-year personal addition and
that that has had to frame the officers
professional opinion tonight so I think
as I'm sensing counts the hook weighs
about to speak I think you've got to be
really clear with your reasoning about
why and how our interpretation of the
evidence which we all seem to have a lot
of empathy with is going to be different
and sustainable over that of the
independent inspector counsel hoc way
Thank You chairman thank you for your
opinion but sorry
just before I speak it's just come to us
sorry it takes low we've had to take
ages out for data protection purposes of
children it is relevant and it is
necessary legally for us to do that
okay counsel aqua Thank You chairman
thank you for Ram for your views and
your opinion I would would like to point
out that the recent sites where it's
gone to an inspector the officer has
stated that on both of those sites there
was already development on those sites
and as I understand it one was a pumping
station and then one had some other and
either building or something on that on
the previous site
you know it says saying that the
examples given about where the other
sites are going to inspectors there was
already some development on those sites
in relation one was a pumping station
and other think had a building or
something on there or some some form of
development on that site it would seem
that this particular site has had no
previous development on it prior to the
works that were carried out without
permission and subject to enforcement
notices so therefore I think that that
is a material consideration because it's
different from from those other other
examples provided we also have a recent
example where consideration of another
application was was taken and and a
different view was taken by the
committee so there is there is an
example of the committee taking a
contrary view to planning off offices
opinion so I would my proposal is for
refusal subject to inappropriate
development in the Greenbelt and there
has not been any proven exceptional
circumstances in relation to this
application
thank you thank you
members we've had a good informed debate
I have a motion for refusal of this item
put forward by Councillor hoc way
seconded by Councillor Cannell on
grounds of inappropriate development in
the Greenbelt and the lack of proof of
an exceptional circumstance those
members in favor of the rejection of
this item please indicate
those games that item is rejected thank
you if our visitors would like to stay
for the rest of the meeting you're quite
welcome if you want to go please feel
free our next item is going to be item
six land to the east of the Rugby Club
Aviation way Rochford
easy spikes have a go huh I was taking
this one flat six okay
Oh Sunday
I saw someone with a phone holder now I
think just to keep the flow of the
meeting going we'll come to that well
well noticed afterwards we'll do all and
talk about it
yeah
so I'm chairman this is a reserved
matters application for consideration of
the infrastructure works in association
with phase two of the approved outline
application in site granted permission
in 2016 the blue line which you can see
roughly along this edge here that's part
of the wider application site and the
red internal line is what we're
considering as part of this planning
application
we'd have plan to please so this the
approved outline quantity permission for
a business park at the wider application
site an updated indicative master plan
is being provided with the current
application shown how the infrastructure
proposed so the infrastructure in buffie
sort of this location how it actually
were alongside the wider business parks
development is actually showing an
indicative of how it could all look it
should be noted that the outline
planning application is the overarching
decision which looked at matters
relating to construction management and
106 contributions it's a name but a few
it is not for the application currently
before us to revisit the matters already
considered as part of this out on
application many of which are controlled
by conditions imposed on the outline
application so this existing layout plan
shows the current situation at the wider
site so a new roundabout has been
constructed here
I wouldn't cherry actual way to the
northwest of the application site along
with a roundabout within the actual
business park itself I'm an aspiring
road linking through to this is the new
location of the west cliff library Club
which is currently under construction
that was approved there was a mass
application and earlier this year if we
have planned the next plan please great
the current reserved matters proposal
includes the spine Road which links
around here like this in a loop it would
have a three metre wide shared footpath
cycle path and a verge which would
surround the outer edge of the access
road no foot parties opposed to the
inside of the loop to access road to its
southern extent a new spur would also be
formed from this road in this location
the proposal was also for green
corridors so these are green sways
running north
South in this location and east-west so
a green ribbon and a green spine they're
being referred to they would cross an
ascent to the site where by foot and
cycle booth will be located broadening
access over the existing ditch we can
have Claire 5 zoom in so that's this is
just a zooming of that cross over going
across an existing page in [ __ ] area
and how that would work with the
landscaping they are proposing
so the key material planning
considerations are hire a public
footpath landscaping service water
drainage and archeology we were asked to
highway the proposed carriageway width
would adhere to the Essex design guide
whilst the shared disciple pathway would
now only occur on one side of the road
this is not considered objectionable
County hi-rez have not raised issue with
such a proposal these changes apply
where the green ribbon dice exercising
in such positions pedestrian crossings
are proposed which would enable safe
crossing to the shared cycle pathway on
the outer edge of the remaining road
county highway see conditions laid into
a gape control and visibility sways to
the new spur which have been included
within the recommendation with regards
to the public footpath a public footpath
proposed in two directions near
north/south footpath would link from the
northern boundary of the wider site down
to aviation way to the south and the
east west footpath would link to a point
close to the north eastern corner and
the wider site and where footpath 36 is
located down to Cherry Orchard Lane to
the west and the boundary of the site
the proposed footpath links are
considered acceptable
the landscaping proposed of green
corridors that considered to comply with
the principle of the landscape and
design codes approved within the outline
application in order to accommodate the
security requirements of Iveco which is
intended to be located in the eastern
area here the proposal now incorporates
the green we've been extending to the
north east to avoid dissector the
intended Apeco site so originally the
proposal was for this to kind of come
across and finish in this location here
but it's part of the reserved mass
application that's currently before us
it would now finish up to this corner
here to allow our ger to have a secure
site in this location and
she's a pending application that we've
got before us at the moment that's been
considered whilst this was not the
intention an outline application stage
the new arrangement is not considered
objectionable the landscaping proposed
is considered provide a variable and
except for mixing designs this just
shows the example where we've got a
variety of sort of native species
ornamental mix some hedging some tree
growth and some benches as well and
being locations here to write quite a
mix of landscape design the council's
arborcoat release raises raises no
objection to the landscaping for host
the county conservation officer raises
concern we've got to screening and
buffering to the northern boundary and
the planning condition has been
suggested to address that concern the
surface water drainage for the scheme
will be located located partly within
the soft landscaped green ribbon using
for detention basins so that's in 1 2 3
for those locations there our planning
condition attached to the approved
outline requires details of drainage
arrangements to be agreed separate to
the current reserved matters application
with regards to archaeology the county
Argonaut archaeological archaeologists
suggest planning condition be imposed
which is considered reasonable this
application is recommended for approval
subject to conditions thank you thank
you members you will notice is a
slightly different layout on on this one
where we have the recommendation at the
front of the report that's the way all
reports will be presented for from this
point on do any members particularly yes
counselor stat oh all right any our
visitors wish to speak first that's a
step down thank you thank you chairman I
have a number of questions if officers
want to like them right there with
regards to the second round new
roundabouts within the site not the one
on the Cherry Orchard way there's a spur
road which travels north as on the
diagram there now under the original
application on the outline that was a
condition that has to be built because
it then goes up to the boundary of the
application site there can you clarify
whether that has been too
has been met with regards to the spur
road running from the to the south into
aviation way can it clarify whether that
will have access on to aviation way and
whether that will be open to traffic I
seem to remember in the original
outlined application that where the
green strip through the center also
included a cycle track is that still the
case can you clarify that with regards
to the you mentioned public footpath
along the green strip there and running
north-south are they to be adopted by
Essex County Council with regards to the
drainage system which is basically this
is the attenuation of the stitches in
sight can you clarify where they will be
discharging to the north of the site was
just off of this drawing here you've got
the river Roche I'm intrigued to know
how it's going to get there
and how that's going to be treated
because being an industrial area there's
bound to be some contamination of that
water how that's going to to be dealt
with there questions I have currently
chairman okay councillor Griffin
Thank You chairman councilors Steptoe
has covered one of my points I just
wanted to find out if the footpaths
could be shared with pedestrians and
cyclists thank you Thank You chairman to
ask the officer in relation to the green
corridors do they follow a natural water
course or some kind of ditch existing
ditch or or are these going to be
completely created from scratch and if
there is a natural water course and the
attenuation basins it would they be
using that water course to to drain into
that cool that's okay for those just to
come back then chairman on those various
questions and the new roundabouts Perth
and it's not part of the current
application that we're considering this
section here and they've already built
so up to this point actually we have got
an interesting
three so they've already constructed
this part so this is what they're
showing is Oh existing layouts this
connection must already be in place on
the site at the moment and if it was a
condition then hopefully will be comply
but it's not for consideration as part
of this current application we've
regards to the access onto Aviation
Raceway can we go back to the other plan
which was please yes thank you so this
access will enable vehicle er access
onto aviation right however there is the
intention for it to be gated control so
that's what County hi rows of requested
by a condition and you'll see that
within the officer recommendation what
condition that that would be limited and
limitation would be at the moment buses
and potentially I pick o who we know are
quite big operators on the the wire that
aviation way and state as well and it
would be for I suppose candy hi rose as
well to consider whether they thought
anything else would be acceptable in
terms of access under aviation way and
we regards to cycle track so the
footpaths running through they are three
meter wide so they are shared cycle
footpaths going north south and east
west and so they'll be used used by
pedestrians and cyclists i'm with
regards to adoption by county council if
they ask that particular distance and
sizing and they are made to the
appropriate standard then it would be
expected that county high roads would be
likely to adopt them it will be for them
to make that final decision and a
student needs to meet certain targets or
requirements that which is which is
there's a county highways we regard the
attenuation and whilst they showing it
at this within this landscaping it's not
actually for consideration at this stage
we have a separate condition as part of
the outline application which deals with
attenuation so if if we were seeing
elements on here which actually didn't
quite work out a later stage we would
need to see a separate application
potentially for soft landscaping on this
site to address that attenuation so
although they are showing detention
basins and i know we have dealt with
some of this show condition to do with
attenuation serviceable to drainage is
part of the Rugby Club and pitch side
here and I believe they're connecting up
at this angle here
at this point but it's not for
consideration as part of this
application it's something we're dealing
with it's part of an outline application
discharge of condition and when that
request will be made to us which we
don't have at the moment so yeah the
only other thing was with God sirs or
the natural flow so we've got there was
actual hedgerow which runs north-south
in this direction so what the applicant
has done is that they've used that as
part of their soft landscaping and to
incorporate it into the design so
they're not trying to remove a lot of
the existing features on the site
they're trying to including existing
features that are already present
hopefully that's fake German if I could
just come back for some clarification
first of all who will have control of
the gate who whose control will that be
even secondly is it can this committee
condition that when the footpaths are
built they are built to the standard
that Essex County Council may wish to or
wish not to actually adopt is that
something we can condition within the
situation that's the whole page you want
to just start
yes thank you I don't think the officer
it's got around to answering the
question as to whether there was a
natural watercourse or or ditch running
through the green areas so with regards
to the actual gate control and details
of that had been submitted to an agreed
so as part of that we can agree and who
would be responsible for the actual
upkeep of the gated control and who
actually would be allowed to use it as
part of that discharge conditional
arrest and with regards to the natural
water cooks again the same as the the
ditch that's the hedgerow that's the
same the they're using sort of existing
water cooks and and hedgerow features
and within the development there was one
more question wasn't there sorry Jared
come back yes it was with regards to the
cycle track being built to the standard
doctoring standards
yes we would we could condition I
believe that so we haven't thought a
commission moment have we regards to the
psychopath but I don't think it's
objectionable to impose a condition
requiring a details of the cycle path to
be agreed in as part of that agreement
we would then discuss with County what
the requirements were that it would have
a separate adoption process which we
wouldn't want to interfere with but that
condition could potentially enable
details to be agreed influent for us to
work with highways to get that
information and together something
possibly could okay yeah I'd be happy
with that but I'd like to see as one of
the one of the written conditions within
the application if I could come back
just to the the gate issue whilst I
understand it's difficult to know who's
going to do and we can't really look at
what might happen in the future but I do
have a concern that there may be if we
if we're not careful with the dated with
the control of the gate whether we would
impede any of the businesses on the
existing state the aviation away a state
of expanding within that new estate and
we don't want to put a call in their way
because that would be a big disadvantage
to some of those businesses so is that
something that we can make sure it
doesn't happen
I think it's
I think the most we could do is we've
got the condition which will allow us to
consider the detail of of who will be
able to be using that gate and I think
that's probably as far as we can go at
the moment with regard to that gate
control and the present time is part of
this current application okay members
we've got an application in front of us
moving for recommendation we've got on
61-62
with the additional item with with
regard to the cycle path and they'd
optimal standard yeah
so those members in favor please
indicate thank you actually another must
be carried thank you very much so we're
now going to move on to item 772 Hockley
Road Raley fits why mark school can this
information on the addendum
just set this one up
chairman this is this application site
is an existing school fix while marking
railey its boundary is outlined in red
you can see here it's surrounded by
residential properties it's got an
access main access off of hoppy road and
it's also got an emergency access
currently disused off of Helena Road
here a public footpath lies to the south
in this location the proposal is for the
demolition of the two existing school
buildings and construction of an
extension to form a new reception and a
new three-story building for teaching
use and dining facilities temporary
buildings will provide a reception
during construction works works the
existing playing pitches multi-use games
area which is yeah new the plan pitches
and temporary Helena Road access would
also take place and the degree of
additional parking would be provided
there were four phases to the
development to please
patiently
so we go to plan two when he opens up
please
so phase one would include a temporary
access formed off of her own erode here
a contract a compound and parking area
located in this area here books have had
the new three-story buildings being
restructured in this location and
groundwork to take place in this area
around here in within the actual pitch
grounds if we could have plan 3 please
so phase 2 we include looking at
temporary buildings around the actual
reception area of the school and we
would they would then be closing off the
actual main carpark area plan for peace
phase 3 it would include demolition of
the two existing buildings location here
with the construction of this extension
highlighted yellow parking from Hell in
a road and a new car park here would be
a temporary measure asked if enable
parking for staff in this location
whilst this car park areas closed to
enable this extension to be constructed
and then after that the final phase
would include removing the actual I've
and the final phase would involve
removing it to the temporary carpark
area reopening this main carpark here
reinstating the playing field where it
been used as a temporary carpark I'm
doing some landscaping and create a
negated access in this location here to
limit the vehicles coming into this area
so this plan it shows the extent of
existing buildings to be removed to form
the way of the new extension so it
looked quite a vast amount of existing
bill form that they're looking to remove
and to make way for the new extension
who could have planned six please so
this shows unfortunately is a bit faint
actually this planned but this we've got
an existing three-story building roughly
in this location with some single-story
elements so yeah
yes sorry about that it's very faint
unfortunately this fan and I don't you
can make any difference if we move we
move on to what's being proposed and I
can come back and show you the existing
and I've got a photograph that hopefully
will show that later
I am soon to move on to the next plan
please
seven please
so this is the amount of new built form
we'll be expecting to see on the site
and if we can see plan eight it will
then show the appearance of the proposal
this is clearer and so we've got its
proposed single-story elevation here
we've a ramped access up going all along
the side as well of the building and
various fenestration works coming along
here we're gonna have plan nine please
we're then move on to the appearance of
the proposed three-story building so
here we've got it we the same scale and
sizing on the three floors but there'll
be used for different purposes so at
ground floor we're looking at dining
facilities I'm and then at first and
ground-floor levels and it will be
teaching facilities we have at those
levels
I'm planned ten so this shows the actual
elevations proposed of the three-story
teaching block with the dining at ground
floor so we're looking at flat roof
building and the proposing white render
and gray brick within their mix of
design so there are various material
planning considerations that were
relevant to this application with
regards to design the general design and
scale of the buildings proposed is
considered acceptable within the context
of the school site the county urban
design and officers have raised issue
with opposed use of materials made up to
seek a predominant use of red brick
rather than graver can render the
applicants queried where the use of gray
brick in some areas of the development
would be possible for cost reasoning
however county urban design have still
raised concern regarding this
considering there's a lesser quality red
brick in such positions should provide a
possible cost solution a condition has
been suggested regarding the use of
materials which can look at the material
options with regards to the playing
fields the proposed new bood will be
sited on part of one of a playing
pitches at the site the applicant seeks
to revise the playing pitch positioning
as a result to mitigate the impact we
look at plan 11 please
yeah
No
so this is the proposal summer
requirements will be met with a change
in running track angles and pitch
positionings
and so we're not looking at a lesser
provision it's a repositioning and a
reacting of exactly what they're
proposing in terms of picture
arrangement on the site and if we look
at plan 12 this would be their winter
pitch arrangement proposal as well go
across the other way it might be hidden
someone else yeah press that one
so this just shows the winter pitch
arrangement here so we've got just again
a mixture of different pitch
positionings and to accommodate the
existing built form or the proposed
built form in this location and the
regrading of some of the pictures around
in this location as well
there is no losses sporting provision
spalled England have raised a Holden
projections of the proposal initially
however upon further discussion they now
no longer object subject to conditions
being imposed these have been included
on the addendum with regard to highways
an increase in staff and pupil numbers
that would result would not give rise to
a significant increase in vehicle
movements to and from the site it is
therefore not considered to have a
severe impact on the highway County
highways raised no objections to the
proposal included in the temporary
Helena road access subject to conditions
it is not considered with the measures
proposed that the temporary access would
generate any highway safety issues ten
new parking bays will be provided in
accordance with parking standards new
cycle spacings will be provided close to
the new building the submitted travel
plan identifies ways to reduce reliance
on the private car however plans to
review this do not continue past
September 2018 a conditional requiring
travel plan monitoring has been
recommended within the officer report
River the surface water drainage and
pros and includes two attenuation tanks
to hold surface water runoff the for
discharge restricted rain into the
existing surface called a drainage
network so the the tanks opposed or in
this location here and also under this
new carpark facility here the lead local
authority have raised a holding
objection until some further information
is provided however officers consider
that suitable surface water drainage
team can be accommodated on the site
based on the details provided one have
suggested the planning condition be
imposed acquiring more details be agreed
and by way of discharge of condition
well regards of ecology the survey
supplied show that to bat species were
recorded but these were foraging and
commuting backs and rather than roosting
at a site no mitigation is therefore
proposed or considered necessary and
we've got with regards to bats on the
site there were two preserved trees
within the playing field none of the
main development works would interfere
with the route protection areas of the
trees there were two surface water
drains that would run through the route
protect
areas and one canopy that would need to
be pruned however the working methods
proposed to addresses are considered
acceptable around 10 columns of lighting
four meters in height I propose to the
car parking areas and walkways along
with some wall-mounted luminaires the
new building so the lighting pose would
be in this location here and then around
this new car parking facility here paul
deters our lighting is suggested by
planning condition however the prince
believed the proposal is considered
acceptable with regards to residential
amenity as residential properties
surround the application site there
would be an impact however such impact
is not considered to be significant and
refusal on ground of residential amenity
is not considered to be justified it
should be noted that Andres was
incorrectly recalled as 14 Louise Road
on the officer report when actually it
should have read 16 just want to draw
that to your attention
we've aghast the noise the location of
new school buildings would be similar to
existing school buildings a respective
neighbor property to the site and the
proposed use of these buildings would
not be considered likely to not rise to
noise which would be detrimental to
level of Mina T that ought to be
reasonably expected by the occupants of
neighboring properties solar panels will
be provided on the new building the
building needs to comply with Bream very
good standard as minimum to adhere to
policy a planning condition
conditionally suggested to this effect
pain and gas have also responded advised
that they have gas operators within the
site the applicant will be required to
contact cadent regarding this the
recommendation chairman is one of
approval subject conditions as outlined
in the report and within the addendum
good evening members my name is Adam
Davis from Stratton Parker and I'm the
planning agent for care consultants who
are the applications for this proposal
at the Fitz y marker school just by way
of background this this scheme is an
Education Skills funding agency funded
scheme rather than a County Council
funded scheme the Education Skills
funding agency undertook an initial
feasibility appraisal for the project
and subsequently appointed kir
construction as their design-build
contractor at the beginning of this year
the proposals have you've heard from
your office's report are for the
modernization of some existing
substandard facilities which will mean
the erection of a new three-story
teaching block with dining facilities
the remodeling of the entrance to
provide a new entrance and reception and
the demolition of some existing
substandard buildings the Kerr design
team have worked on the initial concept
plans which the Education Skills funding
agency prepared and one of the key
changes we have introduced was to move
the three-story block away from the
properties close by and Millfield close
which I think your officers have covered
in the report we were conscious that we
didn't want the new three-story blocked
have any impact on neighboring amenity
through overlooking overshadowing etc
we've worked with the school to ensure
that the scheme is fit for purpose meets
their requirements and as part of the
proposals we've had extensive engagement
we've talked to your office's that
through their pre application process
we've also engaged with the County
Council's urban design team highways and
the county has lead flood authority to
develop the proposals one of the issues
your officer mentioned was a discussion
about the color of the materials we're
happy for the proposed condition within
the officers report and happy to work
with urban design in your planning
officers to agree a suitable brick color
we've also had extensive engagement with
Sport England there is a small loss of
physical loss of playing field but we've
come up with a realignment of pictures
and also the proposals include some
drainage works to improve the
playability of the realigned pitches and
also works to the existing multi-use
games area resurfacing works to make
them more useful usable and more fit for
purpose and these mitigation measures
along with the conditions included in
your report have satisfied Sport England
in May we held a public exhibition and
invited all the local residents
surrounding the development and through
that that consultation exercise there
was general support for the proposals
one of the concerns was about
construction disturbance and some
disturbance with any building project is
inevitable but Kia have submitted a
detailed construction management plan
which will be subject to a condition
they have extensive experience on
working on school projects both new
buildings and expanding existing schools
in constrained urban areas they're very
used to working on this sort of site and
delivering projects and give causing
minimum disturbance to local residents
and also importantly to the school
themselves so the phasing program that's
set out and your officer report has been
designed very much to allow the
buildings to be built the school to move
the children into the new block while
work is carried on round the front of
the building and existing buildings are
removed there's a logic to that phasing
I'd like to thank your officers for the
comprehensive report that they've
submitted before you and their
presentation they've been very helpful
during the processing of the application
and I hope members you'll be able to
support this proposal thank you
just in terms of the recommendation when
we get it sits it's printed on page one
and going through but in the addendum
it's set out the the proposed changes
are set out starting on page six
yeah yourself they're on page six going
going through from 19 and down to the
bottom of page 7 24 over to page 8 for
25 then on page 9 its amendments
proposed to six conditions 6 7 15 and 16
so it's a little bit untidy in the way
it's presented that's where the changes
are all right counselor Stanley you
indicated Thank You chairman two things
really come to mind I know there's going
to be a obviously abatement for the
construction traffic but as that corner
is very very well used by traffic and
also pedestrians especially children and
what have you with the use of the car
park proposed for the teachers to come
in and out of there into using that car
park will there be some sort of a banks
Minh or somebody to control get traffic
as that there's a lot of parking in the
street there um I would like that to be
noted please thank you thank you sparing
then
Thank You chairman can I say I find it
totally unacceptable that I get nine
pages of Correspondence yesterday
evening in relation to this application
I've previously been to the council
offices to discuss this whole
application and I get nine pages of
amendments effectively passed to me
yesterday evening I've had no
opportunity discussing with planning
officers and I don't feel that I've been
able to serve my residents
satisfactorily moving on I accept what
our visitor has said although neither
the ward councillors had any
consultation involvement whatsoever
earlier this year where the residents
were I have no idea but certainly the
ward councillors weren't involved either
a district council level or a town
council level so I've registered that as
well German moving on the more I've gone
into this the more concerns I have about
the whole situation don't get me wrong
we understand the school has got to move
on
we have no problems with that what we
have issues with reading some of this
report very quickly where it's talking
about mitigation of playing fields on a
permanent temporary arrangement talking
about where it will be using securing
community use of the football pitches
outside of school hours I hope we're not
going to go down the same road again
we've been down recently in the last
couple of years about floodlights and
all this sort of issue it's also talking
about Sport England positively to watch
for district councils evolving playing
pitch strategy which has identified
deficiencies in youth football pitches
sorry who have you been talking to we
are closing pitches faster than we can
keep them open at the moment in the last
two years to the best of my knowledge
we've closed ten pitches because there
is no interest in playing youth football
anymore
so that's bringing on another issue but
this is I haven't had the opportunity to
talk about this because it all came in
yesterday evening I don't know I'm
picking up on councillor Stanley I
don't know how long this project is
going to take years I don't know but we
are now talking of whatever length of
project on one of the fastest rat runs
in the district there is no alternative
to move from hotly to Eastwood
vice-versa out to the eastwood road
other than going up Helena Road and I
accept there is issues regarding using a
banks Minh I hope this banks Minh is
going to be there at all times I don't
know how we're going to enforce that is
I don't know how we're going to enforce
parking restrictions because we can't do
it at the moment outside schools we have
a zebra crossing on this very junction
to a facilitate the access we're taking
away a third of a safety barrier that
has been there for to the best of my
knowledge 25 years and probably longer I
fully endorse the comments made by the
resident of 15 Louise Road with regard
to the house safety aspect of this issue
I don't see how they are how this can be
reasonably and safely managed without
some serious enforcement very sorry
about that
I accept that there is issues relating
conditions from Anglian water because of
the potential flooding issues anybody
goes back to 2013 will know exactly what
happened in the hell in the road and all
that sort of area at that time and we
don't seem to be having any idea of
addressing that we are highlighting that
we don't have deliveries between nine
and three sorry I think that is totally
acceptable unacceptable children are
still arriving at nine o'clock and
they're also leaving at three that is
far too tight can somebody please tell
me what happens when all these
subcontractors and they will turn up at
our past eight in the morning twenty
past three in the afternoon or twenty
past two where are they all going to be
situated because they will not all be
able to get into the site they'll be
sitting outside waiting at
to the rat run I have concerns you just
mentioned just now about the flood
lighting we've been down this road as I
say I would like very much more to have
information about the levels of lighting
what's involved and generally I think we
need to make sure that what we are
potentially I say we understand the
school issue but I think we've got to
make very sure the implications that we
are putting on to the potential issues
around the residents living adjacent to
this school are fully addressed Thank
You chairman Thank You chairman I think
counsels parents covered everything
actually and I welcome the upright to
the school it clearly is clearly needs
it's in desperate need of modernization
but I have serious serious concerns over
the access and I would like conditions
in relation to delivery times please not
9 or 3 it's too far to time certainly we
you know where's wall councillors don't
want to have to attend a child's funeral
and can we have some indication please
as to how long this is gonna take thank
you just to come back on some of the
information so we have a construction
management plan submitted as part of the
application and that's provided details
that they will look to use a banks Minh
they've got like you said the delivery
restrictions 9 to 3 that's what they're
proposing and we've answered timescales
and they're looking to complete the
three-story teaching block by September
2019 and then September 2020 for the
actual reception areas so that's the
timescales they're looking for in terms
of the development and Weber gasified
from lighting and just to sort of be
clear they're not proposing I know and I
did actually deal with the application
when we had the the pitch which I know
was very controversial in within this
central area here the light in the
proposing is just safety for the for the
actual car parking and some of the
walkway areas so far see you later and
evening so it's it's just in that area
and in this area here we've obviously
some actually attached to the buildings
as well so it's not flood lighting for
anything pitch based or anything like
that that would have to be the subject
of a complete set for a planning
application I know
mentioned have been made about delivery
time conditions it might be the case
that we could perhaps expand on the
construction management plan condition
we've put on to actually put some hour
restrictions perhaps within that
condition as well perhaps expand on that
and if members felt that was necessary
we did actually go back and I know
concerns have been raised about the
impacts on her in our own Road and the
safety aspects and we went back to
County highways and having been alerted
to that and they wish they still feel
they are happy subject to the conditions
which have been put within the rapport
that they are not concerned from a
highway safety perspective about the the
temporal use of that that access way for
the time period or the construction
works and they say that's that's that's
counting and views on that okay so any
other of our visiting members should you
want to continue thank you and I need
confirmation that this will be enforced
if there's any issues I would also and
I'm sure my colleagues as well
councillors want to be kept up to date
with any issues we will be watching very
closely and we have one of our
counselors have been very close to the
facility but I certainly and I know
counselor Spearin will be visiting
frequently thank you okay okay yes thank
you chairman and I totally agree with
the counselor realm counselors bearing
the saying that in terms of the concerns
I did write down here that I had a
concern about the mixture of kids and
trucks one of the thing that they do do
in London quite frequently particularly
in London where sites are quite
restricted in their turn
excess is that the trades is called and
tradesmen have to be on site by a given
time otherwise they don't have access to
the site I would suggest that might be a
way of actually doing that have a
concerned about Clara confirming if I'm
correct me if I'm wrong that you're
saying no deliveries between nine and
three but outside of those hours you
could have deliveries I would say if
deliveries only between nine and three
okay I wasn't sure if I got that right
way around I would suggest that needs to
be reduced I would have suggested that
needs to be between ten and probably two
there's probably where I would suggest
that needs to be the other thing where I
do have a concern like any school pick a
school anywhere in the country and
you've got a problem with the car
parking kids being dropped off from
school you know that was mentioned that
there is a access of foot path through
to the how is it held in the road at the
back there which children were no doubt
will use to gain access to the school
there is a scheme which is run by the
southeast each parking partnership on
behalf of as care to council called cp3
which actually helps a great deal with
parking issues around schools can I
suggest that perhaps we encourage the
school or perhaps even some sort of
condition that the school adopt that and
that may help a nice some of the
problems Thanks
I think clearly there's going to be a
lot of discussion about traffic
management we're not in a position here
as a committee to determine what the
traffic management plan is but I think I
would suggest as a condition that the
final details of the submitted and
agreed traffic management plan be agreed
in consulting in consultation with the
ward councillors yes at the moment we've
got construction management plan
condition which says to be in accordance
with what they've submitted but if you
want more details to be sort of agreed
differing to what we've currently been
put before us and I think we amend that
condition to say construction management
plan to be submitted to and agreed and
so we can amend some in consultation
with them all to excellent yeah members
happy for that to go as a an amendment
to the proposal that we'll be talking
about okay that's a Western
yes just equipment on the chairman on
the only traffic once this I mean I
agree with everybody once this call has
been completed and finished my problem I
have is like when most colleges is there
enough Sparkle spaces a for the teachers
and whatever teachers are working at
school but I've also got a very big
concern of where mums and dads in the
morning dew dew drop off their children
as we've said because I go past it every
morning and I get stuck on the
roundabouts bus can't get in the bus
line is there any anything on this plan
that the mums and dads can go into the
school like like a very current rounds
they can come out again like to do it
Koreans would Lane it's just a question
really so we've got the first part of
your question and they're the expansion
would look to provide accommodation for
an additional 150 students and our
parking stand requirement is initial one
parking space per 15 so they're
providing the in accordance with our
parking standards document at 10 spaces
that would be needed and the we're not
considering as part of this application
they haven't got drop-off facilities
we've actually in the ground it fits why
I'm at school they've got they providers
we've a travel plan and we've put a
condition on with regards to monitoring
and wanting more detail around that
travel plan and with regards to sort of
making sure that the travel arrangements
with students is continued to be
improved and we've allowed to fix while
I'm at school but they haven't got and I
think it'd be going perhaps too far as
part of this application requiring any
particular drop-off facilities and
moving the actual ground to the school
itself when it's not something they
currently encourage for safety reasons I
believe that's the whole Quay
jaymund I know we've stated about there
the access and the management plans but
I just want to make a little comment in
relation to Steptoe proposed in
restriction of the times and that I
think the only danger of that ease is if
you make it too restrictive for the
trade you might end up doing is making a
two-year bill be ended up being a
three-year build because you've got
you've got to be reasonable with with
accessibility the the thing that I was
gonna ask because I'm just not
completely clear with this you've got a
temporary access from Helena Road is
that is that purely a Vinick vehicle
access point with regard to students and
schoolchildren are they still accessing
the school facilities in the same way as
they do currently is there any
indication that's part of the proposal
in this the various stages that that
changes at all the the temporary access
off of Helen the road would be purely a
via killer and so there was a public
public footpath which runs alongside the
bottom of that which feeds down to the
to the bottom of the sort of school age
and pops background I'm it would not be
expected that students use that
temporary access or there be any
pedestrian uses it's purely for the
construction and vehicles while the
actual three-story blocks constructed
and then after that for the staff car
parking while they do the reception
areas members we have a series of
recommendations with amendments on the
addendum and with the details of the
traffic management plan to be consulted
on with ward councillors you say
anything else before we vote no okay
those members in favor
of the recommendation for approval
please indicate thank you that is
unanimously approved thank you very much
for time tonight
closed meeting at 921 ish thank you